Mr Buffett how can I make 30 billion
dollars start you on them the big thing
about it is we started building this
little snowball on top of a very long
hill so we started a very early age
enrolling the snowball down and of
course the snowball the nature of
compound interest is it behaves like a
snowball of sticky snow and the trick is
to have a very long hill which means
either starting very young or living
very to be very old you know I would do
it exactly the same way if I were doing
it in the investment world I mean if I
were getting out of school today and I
had ten thousand dollars to invest I'd
start with the A's I would start going
right through companies and I I probably
would focus on smaller companies because
I would be working with smaller sums and
there's more chance that something is
overlooked I mean you have to buy
businesses and you or little pieces of
businesses called stocks and you have to
buy them at attractive prices and you
have to buy into good businesses and
that advice will be the same 100 years
from now in terms of investing that's
that's what it's all about and you can't
expect anybody else to do it for you
you've got to learn what you what you
know and what you don't know and within
the arena what you know you have to just
pursue it very vigorously and act on it
when you find it you can't look around
for people to agree with you you know
you have to think for yourself do
something you're very passionate about
and don't try to chase what is kind of
the hot Passion of the day I think we
saw it in the internet World quite a bit
where you know at the sort of peak of
the internet in say 1999 found people
who were very passionate something that
kind of left that job and decided I'm
going to you know do something in the
internet because it's you know it was
almost like the 1849 gold rush in a way
at that time everybody who was in within
the shouting distance of California was
you know they might have been a doctor
but they quit being a doctor and they
started panning for gold and that almost
never works and even if it does work you
know According to some Metric financial
success or whatever it might be I
suspect it leaves you ultimately
unsatisfied so you really need to be
very clear with yourself and I think one
of the best ways to do that is this
notion of projecting yourself forward to
age 80 looking back on your life and
trying to make sure you've minimized the
number of regrets you have that works
for career decisions it works for family
decisions yeah I mean you can fake it
too make it in a lot of areas
particularly if you're working for
somebody else but at the end of the day
if you're going to be great at something
you've got to make the effort to be
great at something whether it's Sports
whether it's physics math science
business whatever it may be you know
it's not just a natural skill you've got
to to learn and particularly if you're
in the technology industry because it
changes every day you know when I got
started I was a bartender when I first
came to Dallas got into the PC industry
got fired started my own company but I
learned early on that there was always
something new and most people didn't put
in the time to learn it it's like now
with artificial intelligence lots of
people talk about artificial
intelligence lots of people talk about
machine learning and neural networks not
a lot of people are putting in the time
to take classes or do the tutorials or
to learn how to apply it to business and
that's what it takes and you know that's
just something I've always enjoyed so
I've been fortunate for me it's if
you're spending money on marketing are
you constantly experimenting with new
ideas so I've always said to my
companies I want a third of marketing to
be experimental every quarter because if
you're just sitting on your laurels
doing the same old crap you're missing
out and your competitors are going to do
something else so start experimenting
because the value of something that
works that you find through just
creative chaos is extremely higher than
what you've already been doing because
you start losing yields right away
whatever your strategy is and let's say
you're getting a two percent response on
it watch six months from now it'll be
1.7 or 1.5 what's the next thing what's
the next idea what's the next drop
what's new because it's so noisy out
there as you all know you've got to keep
creating and everybody has the tools to
do that also at
inaction of after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there hard work will not make you rich I
get driven nuts by the amount of gurus
and influencers and whatever who want to
brag and say no one can outwork me I'm
the best in the world so many people
outwork me I still make more money than
them there has to be something else one
of the things that grinds my gears about
a lot of people that I see on Instagram
that you probably see too is this whole
like no one can outwork me Mantra first
off it's objectively false because many
people a out working today the outward
gift in the past see you haven't met
everyone indeed it doesn't
matter anyways it's the same thing when
someone's like I'm the best and you have
to say you're the best because if you
don't think you're the best it shows
that you're not confident to me I don't
take that at all if someone's like I'm
the best then why aren't you on
billboards that's what the best would
look like absolutely you need to do the
work you need to put volume in it's the
only way you get better but if you start
claiming that you are the best you
cannot be outworked you are making
statements that you know are not true
why are we bragging about work because
work has very little to do with the
highest levels of the game Warren
Buffett talks about if he makes two good
decisions a year he's had a good year
and so how is it that one of the best
investors one of the best business
people in terms of measuring it by money
which is how you measure business talks
about how he does basically nothing
reads five or six hours a day eats
McDonald's and makes a couple good
decisions a year how is it that that guy
is making so much more money than the
people who are bragging about the fact
that they work so hard no money that you
have is not the issue it doesn't
actually take money to make money it
takes courage to make money it takes
contacts to make money money is a
contact sport I need to make contact
with people okay it's not about skills
it's not about education it's not about
personality it's about context the more
contacts I make the more chances I
hey would you rather a billion friends
or a billion dollars I said dude give me
a billion friends billion friends is
worth at least five or ten billion
dollars a billion dollars is only a
billion dollars and if I can actually go
make contact with a billion people and
get them to trade money with me just
five percent of those people just five
percent of those people gave me a
hundred dollars because I traded some
service that was worth a thousand I'd be
worth five billion dollars so see most
people don't understand the math the
money money is not about numbers money
is about people so the fortunate thing
was I had a rich dad and I learned about
money early and you know so I keep
asking people what does school teach you
about money nothing that's why so many
guys aren't rich but my poor dad was a
PhD in education and no money at all and
I didn't want to follow in his footsteps
so I started off with Rich Dad Poor Dad
and my rich dad was the one teaching me
how to be a successful I wanted to be an
entrepreneur but Rich Dad said to me
says you got to learn how to sell now my
poor dad bought sales into a scum so I
had death going in my head so my rich
dad says
that was in my head so I said it to my
wrist I said but I don't want to sell I
went to work for Xerox because they're
the best sales training so I was flown
from Hawaii to Leesburg Virginia and
learned how to sell and all this and I
realized then is that sales equals
income but in all areas of life you
cannot sell you cannot communicate
cannot Market a toast when you've
managed doubt and you jump and you jump
with the intention to fly and you fail
be willing to fail but don't fail and
just fall because if you fail and just
fall all you're going to do from that
point is collect evidence why you should
never leap again oh no the last time I
leave this happened but if you leap and
you fall and you call it a failure just
be committed to do what I do I fail I
fail more than most failure says so many
things number one failure says I took a
leap so first congratulate yourself we
tend to only focus on what didn't work
so in my company we always face fell
forward that's our commitment we're
going to fail guys because we're playing
big enough and oh by the way the bigger
you play the more you fail because
you're doing more things you're up to
more things I don't want to live a safe
life I want my life to be threaded with
failures because if it's threaded with
failures then it's threaded even with
even more places where I play Big I took
a leap I risked I took a chance on
myself take a chance on yourself at the
risk of failing just always be committed
to fail forward because when you fell
forward your failure has context an
abundance mindset is the belief that
there is nothing truly scarce so we grew
up as a human species in scarcity and
our physiology and our the way our brain
is watered for scarcity if I have an
orange tree I'm I'm five five I grab the
oranges from the lowest hanging branches
all of a sudden orange tree oranges are
scarce again until I invent a piece of
technology called a ladder that gives me
higher reach and now I've got access to
oranges again if you've got a pie and
you've got family a four Camaro for
dinner but then all your neighbors hear
about and they all come for dinner you
have to slice the pie in a thinner and
thinner slices in an abundance mind says
like we're gonna go bake more pies the
realization is technology is turning
whatever used to be scarce into
abundance the realization is there is
nothing truly scarce you know an
exponential mindset is we evolved in a
local and linear world nothing changed
the life of your great great great great
great grandparents and the life of your
great great great great grandchildren
was the same right over Millennia that
was it but today we're living in a world
where technology is growing
exponentially things are not changing
Century to Century or decade to decade
they're changing year to year and so an
exponential mindset is understanding how
computation centers and then Works AI
robotics 3D printing synthetic biology
augmented virtual reality web3 how all
these Technologies are just are
transforming what each of us can do in
our lives how do you balance your life I
mean with this distress with so many
different you know you're on so many
different companies but how do you
balance it well I mean I
should point out that I a 20-hour work
day is relatively unusual and and rather
painful but I I do sleep six hours a
night so and if I sleep less than six
hours and I I find that I am I might be
awake longer but I get less done I'm not
suggesting this is good for everyone and
I think frankly I would like to work a
bit less than that because I went
through some very difficult times where
it was on the Ragged edge of survival
and if I didn't give it everything I got
it the company could have easily gone
bankrupt it was really on the verge
bankruptcy for quite a while I don't
mean to suggest complacency at this
point but uh you know it does require
much less work to operate Tesla Now
versus say in the 2017 to 2019 time
frame Twitter is still somewhat of a
startup in reverse and so there's a lot
of work required here to get Twitter to
a sort of a stable position and uh like
I said to really build the engine of
engineering of software engineering at a
Twitter and have it um you know really
have a like sort of a great product
roadmap and and of the people in place
to implement that product roadmap and so
it is not my intention to work like
crazy in the mid 1980s a philosopher and
theologian by the name of Dr James cars
to find these two types of games finite
games and infinite games a finite game
is defined as known players fixed rules
and an agreed upon objective football
baseball there's always a beginning
middle and an end and if there is a
winner then necessarily there have to be
losers then you have infinite games
infinite games are defined as known and
unknown players which means you don't
necessarily know who all the other
players are and new players can join at
any time the rules are changeable which
means every player can play however they
want and the objective is to perpetuate
the game to stay in the game as long as
possible we are players in infinite
games every day of Our Lives whether we
know it or not there's no such thing as
winning education you can come in first
for the finite amount of time you're at
school where we agree upon the time
frame and the metrics grades but nobody
wins education nobody wins health care
nobody wins global politics and there's
definitely no such thing as winning
business
process of doing something you actually
like is my great addiction the fact that
I am able to actually wake up day in and
day out sleep easily for seven eight
hours a night and wake up genuinely
excited while always being prepared to
grab my phone and know that I have a
problem in my 300 person Singapore
office or something happened in LA or
one of the other 17 businesses that I'm
associated with are in trouble I sit on
top of almost 3 000 employees and two
very large businesses actively as the
CEO and then on the board of four others
and heavily invested in others and many
other things I'm involved with I have
plenty going on but the fact that I do
what I want to do enables all of it to
work this is grounded in something that
is the absolute answer for this entire
Arena the one thing I can absolutely
speak on that fundamentally touches
every person here is the relationship
between self-esteem and insecurity all
of the things that you do are based on
if you look at what's really been going
on with people for a very long time why
when one is sold fear that they believe
it versus when they're sold fear that
they don't why so few people have a
framework of believing in optimism
versus protecting themselves with
cynicism why people lack patience I can
tell you right now that for the majority
of people in this room that want
something to happen the biggest flaw in
their mental framework and perspective
is their lack of patience it is why I
make so much content around people that
are 22 25 35 40 and laughing and joking
and trying to some way somehow
communicate to them that they are
extremely young
I'm going to teach you the entrepreneur
success formula this is the formula it's
very simple it's easy to apply that when
you actually execute it it will change
the course of your life and your
business the entrepreneur success
formula are you ready you need to if you
want to have success as an entrepreneur
combine what you love doing with what
brings value to other people
people messes up what you love doing
with what brings value to other people
in that intersection is your next great
genius amazing business idea here's what
most people do
most people just pick one
most people either pick what they love
doing
but they can't figure out how to bring
value to other people so you've got a
hobby if you love doing something it
just fills you up it's amazing but it
never brings value to other people then
you never get paid you've got a really
fulfilling Hobby and that could be great
and your hobby can be something you do
in the evenings and weekends and it
fills up your soul but you'll never turn
that into a business if you don't figure
out how to bring value to other people
so you're stuck always having to have a
job or go work for somebody else while
you're doing your hobby on the on the
weekends evenings on the side Etc so
those are the people who just Chase what
they love doing right they chase Your
Passion amazing
there's other people a lot of
entrepreneurs who just go after the
money
just try to bring value just go after
opportunity right that's the only focus
like I'll do whatever it takes I need to
be a millionaire by the time I'm X years
old I'll do whatever it takes but you
won't you will not do whatever it takes
because as soon as it gets hard you're
gonna lose and the problem is you're
going up against people who love it pick
whatever industry you open up a magazine
or website it shows you the hottest
businesses for next year these are the
industries that will take off and you
have to get into it it's like oh wow
that's hot I'm gonna go off and do those
things if you don't absolutely love it
right this part here if you don't
actually love it what you love doing
with what brings value to other people
if you don't absolutely love it
You're Gonna Lose because you're going
up against people who do love it if it's
just a strategy for you but for other
people they love it you're going to lose
every time you can lose every time
because while you're counting the hours
and while you're trying to figure oh my
gosh when is this going to pay off
you're going up against people who
aren't even tracking it who get lost in
it who 12 hours later they're still
doing a thing because they love it so
much and they can't believe that where
is the time gone
so it has to be in that combination so
many entrepreneurs start a business
because if they're going to make a lot
of money and they end up going broke and
it wasn't because the idea was bad the
idea could have been fantastic the
problem was you didn't love it enough
you didn't care about it enough it was
just a strategy it's just an opportunity
for you instead of being actually
something that you love so the
entrepreneur's success formula
you start with doing what you love
and then you figure out how to bring
value to other people doing it another
way I like to explain it is your heart
and your head so you make the big
decisions in life with your heart on the
small ones with your head what you work
on what you do what you're what you're
spending your time on day in day it has
to be heart driven it's got to be
something that fills you up with so much
joy but then your head needs to be part
of the equation too to say okay okay
heart that's great that you love doing
this thing but how are we going to make
money how we're going to bring value to
other people so you make the big
decisions with your heart and then you
use your head to figure out how to make
it actually practical so you're not just
daydreaming constantly in la la land
we're actually turning it into something
that can have a massive impact on the
world
the entrepreneur success formula you
gotta do what you love
and figure out a way to bring value to
other people doing it
when I started making my YouTube channel
I never thought I was going to make
money I did it because I love doing I
did it because I wanted visual content
I'm a visual learner
I struggled in reading books it took me
a long time when I read a book unless
it's really short chapters and and
really spaced out well I would find
myself reading five pages of the book
and then
realizing I read five pages and I have
no idea what I just read so I had to go
back and read those five pages again I
would look how long a chapter was and
see oh my gosh it's 40 pages this
chapter is going to kill me I read
because I I needed to because I wanted
knowledge but it was a really
inefficient way for me to learn I'm a
visual learner I like to see things and
so I said well why hasn't somebody made
this
and I wanted to be around successful
famous entrepreneurs because I didn't
have anybody in my life who had achieved
what I wanted to achieve and so that was
the root of why I started making my my
videos and my content and before YouTube
I had my website which was similar idea
of sharing the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and what you can learn
from their success
so I did it for myself
and then figured out how can I do this
so that I can make money doing it so
that I can do this as my full-time thing
so that I can recruit a team of people
to help me do this so now we've got a
team of people who are all building
these channels with me so I can create
even more impact and make even more
videos
the combination LED first with what I
love doing I want to create content that
speaks to 19 year old Evan who was
struggling who doesn't know what to do
who who's making 300 bucks a month was
broke who wanted to do something big but
had very little belief in himself and
and didn't have a plan for what to do
next I still make my videos for 19 year
old Evan
and I had to figure out a way to turn it
into a profitable business so that I can
have a bigger reach and be able to do
this full-time plus and have a team to
help me do it
entrepreneur success formula what you
love doing with what brings value to
other people okay so how do we do it how
do we start to figure out that process
that's an easy formula but underneath it
let's let's dive a little deeper to give
you even more value step number one is
embrace the end most people are thinking
or most people are thinking do I do this
or doing this do I do this business or
do this business if you think about your
passions and your interests right what
do you love doing what's your heart
centered thing that you could do all day
you probably have a couple things and
you feel like you have to pick this is
the mistake people feel like you have to
pick you don't have to pick the actual
selection is in doing both of those
things combined a lot of people have
said some amazing things of me is very
humbling I think of Ed mylett and
garyvee where garyvee called me the DJ
that likes to watch so much content and
then spin it to inspire people and Ed
mylett said that I'm the modern day
Napoleon Hill Napoleon Hill is the
biggest influence of all time personal
development and I'm the modern day
Napoleon Hill first off that's
extremely humbling but
why are they saying that this is how I'm
unique because I love consuming all of
this stuff and I love spinning it and
mixing it up as well as adding my own
message to things this is how I'm
Different there's a lot of people who
are just sharing their message and
there's a lot of people who are also
mixing things together but there's
nobody who's really mixing things
together and sharing their own message
right so instead of looking at those two
things as different Brian's like I have
to pick I got to pick this or this like
I'm going to combine them and that's how
I'm going to be unique so think about
your different interests what do you
love doing what are what are your top
two three things that you can get lost
in and they feel completely different
your Genius is going to be in actually
mixing those things together in a way
that's never been done before and then
usually not to bring value to people
stop thinking or and instead embrace the
end step number two is try to get as
close to customers as possible so it's
great to be making it's big it's great
to be creating it's great to be you know
imagineering of where you could go
when you start to solve the problem for
yourself that's a great step one because
there's probably a lot of people who
currently are who you used to be and
seeing how you solved it for yourself
sharing the videos I need the videos for
myself and then I share them and it
helps other people right so I solved the
problem for me first you solve the
problem for you first I know there's
lots of people like you but you need to
start talking to customers you need to
start getting their feedback you need to
start seeing what they interact with and
that can help guide a lot of your future
product or service creation you need to
get out of just sitting by yourself on
your couch researching and into actually
talking to people so a quick example
from my channel
the whole top 10 rules for Success thing
came because I just made one video on
Kanye West that's why he's you know on
the wall behind me made one video on him
and then people started requesting more
hey can you do Dame Dash hey can you do
Jay-Z hey can you do Jeff Bezos hey can
you do Steve Jobs hey can you do these
people and
it's like well that's a cool idea sure
why not I could do that I never thought
of it as being a whole series I just was
wanted to give a tribute to Kanye West
and it was a one-off video
and then in the videos that people were
suggesting can you do this person this
person this person this person I still
get final say we ended up having over 2
000 different requests for people to
profile I still get final sales to who
we profile
because I have to feel connected to the
message and when I'm pulling out the
content if we're doing Kanye West or
Steve Jobs is always something positive
it's always through the lens of belief
because that's what I want to put out I
don't want to put out Kanye West's
biggest attacks or insults or negativity
I want to put out negativity in the
world I could easily done top 10 top 10
Kanye West stupidest things you've ever
done I'm not interested in putting that
out
so it's that combination of what people
are asking for hey can you do this can
you do that can you do this plus what I
love doing right what I want to put my
steak in the ground to say I made this
right this is the contribution that I'm
trying to make to the world back to the
entrepreneur success formula right what
you love doing with what brings value to
other people so how to figure out what
brings value to other people you have to
get as close to the customer as possible
understand their business understand
what they're going through understand
their mindset you solving the problem
for yourself is a good first step and
then going into okay what are you
struggling with so number one is embrace
the end number two is get as close as
possible to the customer and then number
three is solve a problem solve a problem
as you're talking to customers
as you're talking to people who will be
using your product or your service who
will be engaging with your content as
you're talking to these people what is
the problem that they're facing
what is the struggle what is the
challenge that they're facing and then
help them accomplish it
if I apply it to myself and the YouTube
channels for context
one of the biggest challenges I think
people have is a very poor environment
you've got people in your life who keep
you where you are some people may be
telling you that you can't do things
that's the worst case scenario some
people might be cheering you on but they
can't guide you you're not inspired by
them the people around you are not
inspiring enough for you and that's why
you're stuck because the environment is
keeping you small
where if you're around higher Achievers
if you're around Tom bilyu and Oprah
Winfrey and Elon Musk and these people
they would pull you to be better and so
that's the biggest problem that I see
the entrepreneurs that I love helping is
you know you're capable of more you've
got this big mission inside you you've
got the heart and the care and the
willingness to serve you've got
everything but you're not being pulled
forward by anybody
and so I want to try to create that
through content because you may not be
able to hang out with Tom bilio and Elon
musking up or Winfrey but every day on
YouTube you can hang out with Tom Billy
Elon Musk and Oprah Winfrey from the
content that I'm going to make and
create right so that's the problem that
I'm trying to solve
and I get that because it was me who
struggled with it but also the people
that I see who I connect with who are
watching the videos they're leaving
feedback from me and I'm talking to them
and I realize you've got everything
you've got everything you you've got
everything you're just missing that
environment to push you forward so
that's the problem that I solve what is
the problem that you solve when you can
combine your passions right step number
one you combine in your passions
step number two is we're talking to
customers people who are going to use
potentially what we can create and then
you're understanding what their problem
is and you solve it for them
that's how we start to build a
successful business
back to the entrepreneur success formula
if you get this formula if you apply it
it's simple it's basic and it's one of
the most powerful things you can ever do
and it's the one of the biggest reasons
why entrepreneurs don't win
despite having the heart and the care
and the service you have to combine the
thing that you love doing with all your
heart with something that brings value
to other people
bring those things together and you're
on to your next successful business
career
good luck because you made it this far
in a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome
to learn how to set goals and make them
happen check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there this is
the hard part for most people can you
teach your body emotionally what the
future will feel like before it happens
that means you're not waiting for your
wealth to feel abundant you're not
waiting for your success